bruce how how you doing buddy
hey pop how's it going great to see you
i know i'm i'm very excited about this
let me start with uh
how do you view bitcoin in politics
today we obviously are recording this on
the day that uh senator lumus and
senator gildebrand uh come together with
bipartisan legislation uh and they want
to pull uh bitcoin and digital assets
further into uh kind of regulatory
clarity and and the financial system
what's your read on the relationship
between you know politics and and this
corner of finance and bitcoin and crypto
well it's certainly getting you know
more and more intertwined i mean i think
that struck a lot of us who've been in
the space a while you know you down in
miami that for example there was an
event senator lumus was there i was
there uh blake master several other
candidates i think there was probably
over a dozen candidates for federal
office that were there and a few other
people who already hold office a couple
congress members and uh at least one
senator senator lomas so and then
there's the mayor's there of course so
it's it's quite intertwined uh i'm not
sure that's a good thing i think there's
a lot of politicians who kind of jump
into this because they see it as a
fundraising opportunity or whatever and
uh you know overall i'm against
regulation obviously so i'm not a fan of
uh politicians uh meddling in this
business but it is certainly an
interesting phenomenon to see how
they've uh you know you know kind of uh
integrated into this space
how can people evaluate candidates in
terms of who actually understands what
they're talking about and who doesn't
and uh i won't put you on the spot i'll
throw out a candidate that uh i had high
hopes for and maybe has disappointed
which is the new york city mayor so the
mayor oh yeah you know one of the
largest cities uh came out said he was
going to take paycheck and bitcoin uh
was saying you know a lot of the right
things i think people were like oh okay
this is a big switch for new york city
from where they were uh gets in office
and then almost immediately starts
talking about you know proof of work is
stupid and uh you know
obviously gets uh a viewpoint that shows
he doesn't really understand uh the
value of the technology doesn't
understand how it works so what's your
suggestion to folks in terms of the
framework they could use to
analyze a political candidate
or the ability for them to understand
who actually understands this and has
kind of the right thought process or not
yeah i think that you need to analyze
candidates based on what their
fundamental principles are and ideally
it's interesting uh ideally they
wouldn't need to know about it somebody
um the other day was talking about
an entirely different industry and uh
you know asking you know how much
knowledge they should have really
politicians shouldn't need to know
anything ideally they should just mind
our own business because the the people
in washington dc aren't going to know
what you know jesse powell or brian
armstrong or sam are doing uh better
than those people are doing the people
who are leading industries you know the
people who are uh ceos and business
owners small business owners large
business owners individual workers
they're the ones who should be making
the decisions about their own industry
so ideally you have politicians that you
know don't really even need to know they
shouldn't need to know what's going on
in bitcoin they should just say it's
none of our business let those
bitcoiners do their thing let the crypto
people do their thing let the ethereums
and the xrp's let everybody do their
thing you know it's not government's
place to uh to interfere so that's what
i would look for and that's what i would
look for in a candidate that's what i
look for when i vote and when i support
other candidates i look for people who
have a you know fundamental moral
philosophy of peace and non-intervention
and not having government in our
business so it's a it's a fundamental
belief and that would have been obvious
with uh adams from new york you know it
was very clear that he's a tyrant
authoritarian statist you know so i
didn't buy him for one second when he
said he was a bitcoiner i think it's
fundamentally ideologically opposed and
you know he was in favor of all kinds of
movement passes and you know mass
mandates and these kind of things so it
shouldn't surprise people at all because
he doesn't have that you know
fundamental you know moral foundation
that that you should have if you're
running for office
when you start to think about uh
regulation you've mentioned a couple
times that politicians just stay out of
it uh i think the counter-argument from
a politician that wants to be very
heavily involved is something like uh
terra or luna uh maybe some of the rug
polls in the defy world etc how do you
balance what uh i would label as uh more
of a libertarian view on uh keep
government out of this stuff uh which i
think is probably the dominant uh
viewpoint of people in the bitcoin
community uh with many of the um you
know kind of uh outlier catastrophes
that have occurred uh in the larger
crypto ecosystem like how do you just
balance those two things
yeah so the first thing is you know
these tragedies are terrible you know
people lose a lot of money sometimes
they lose their life savings in some
cases you know people lose their lives
over it you know it's a very very
serious thing uh but there's two things
to think about one does can the
regulation stop these things you know
can regulation prevent another luna i
would say probably not
because bernie madoff was the biggest
fraud of all time and he was head of the
largest regulator so there's people who
are regulated there's all kinds of
frauds enron and other things so there's
a lot of overhead for these regulations
and it's not really clear it's not like
we have a world where we choose either
you know no regulations or we have
regulations then everything is fine you
know everything is not fun with
regulations we still have fraud but we
still but we have this also huge huge
huge burden on society and on businesses
so i would prefer to not have the
regulations and the way
will there be drawbacks of that sure but
there's a lot of advantages you know
about half of the industry spends about
half of its time dealing with compliance
and lawyers you talk to many ceos just
as i do all the time and uh
you know you know that a big chunk of
their time is focused with lawyers and
and compliance and that's a shame now
there's drain on our economy so people
should be able to have a bit more
freedom and uh you know there's some
drawbacks of that you'll have bad things
happen but you'll also have bad things
happen if you have people like madoff
and other politicians and other people
trying to run your lives you'll also
have bad things happen so either way
you're gonna have bad things happen um i
prefer a market uh system where things
like luna can reset you know people
would not if 2016 or 17 white paper and
tried to market it right now it wouldn't
work because the market has regulated
itself and
although they've tried luna 2 i don't
think that'll work too much and i know
that we won't see luna 3
unless they really clean up their act
and the market believes it you know
so the market is a very very efficient
regulator in many ways and and that's
the regulator that i prefer market is a
very very efficient regulator in many
ways and and that's the regulator that i
prefer
talk about central bank digital
currencies right you're running for
political office uh it seems like
central banks and politicians around the
world get super excited like oh that
bitcoin thing that's really cool let's
just take the same technology and create
our own uh how do you view central bank
digital currencies is that something the
u.s government should get involved in or
should they stay out of it
they should stay out of it they are
central bank digital currencies are and
i'm really glad you asked this because
this is important central bank digital
currencies are a really really serious
problem
everybody not just crypto people
especially crypto people we need to be
sounding alarm we need to be telling our
neighbors and our friends say hey
remember you listened didn't or didn't
listen to us about bitcoin many years
ago or whatever you got to listen to us
now about cbdc's because they represent
one of the greatest threats to freedom
and human freedom and the future that
we've ever seen and it and it's very
sneaky it's not in the form of a tank
it's not somebody putting a gun in your
face but what it is is it represents the
power
of government and officials who have
already shown their desire to censor
people and their willingness to be
authoritarian it gives them the power to
shut off our money
and in a digital world the kind of world
that we're in now that's a power that we
cannot allow politicians to have if we
allow them to have that power
it's game over we lose our freedom we
lose our country because we're simply
one bad politician away
and there's people whether you're right
or left whether
your nightmare is pelosi or trump
whoever that politician is you you
dislike picture somebody even worse than
them if they have the power of a cbdc
where they can shut off your money that
means no protesting it means i can't pay
my internet i can't be on your show
it means game over they could completely
and totally quell protest and quell
speech and movement and activities and
all kinds of other things so we just
can't gain that power it doesn't matter
how good they are and how much you like
them we can never ever give them that
power we cannot give them that power
because if they have it it's too great
of a power for politicians to have so
i'm really really against cbdc's i'd
like to fight them
what do you think is the way to fight
him is it just free market competition
and bitcoin becomes uh superior and
adopted globally and and then the cbdc's
end up not being valuable do you think
there's uh regulations that should be
put forward that they can't actually go
and create it like how do you uh
put obstacles in the way of cbdc's or or
stop them
yeah well we certainly hopefully bitcoin
is better money and that wins out
eventually um
you you could actually have regulations
to prevent them what the kind of things
that i would uh sponsor or support if
i'm a kid would prevent we cannot allow
a money that has built-in ability for
government to shut it down we just can't
so that would be something that should
be illegal in the united states the
united states government should not have
the ability they don't have the ability
right now with the dollar so this would
be a new power that they would have i
would be absolutely completely adamantly
against any bill that was trying to add
that uh and and i'd probably even take
the extra step of um you know certainly
being willing to vote for or even
sponsor legislation that said you can't
do it so you have a you know i have
legislation that says you know
government absolutely can never shut
your money off and they can never track
it doesn't matter who you are or why or
if you're terrorist or whatever horrible
thing they're going to come up with as
an excuse of why cannot allow it we just
can't allow government to have that
power it's too much power for them to
have and i don't trust them and i think
anybody who does trust them right now is
crazy so especially these days when when
you look at the russia ukraine situation
obviously there's been a lot of
financial sanctions that have been
levied uh one what's your kind of read
on that but also two is that a nail in
the coffin for the u.s dollar as a
global reserve currency once other
nation states realize that the u.s will
use these powers uh to uh sanction them
and cut them off from the financial
system on a us dollar basis
yeah money needs to be fungible so
um you know being shut off that's a
problem that's another problem with
cbdc's on a global level so
i don't know if it's the nail in the
coffin there's a lot of nails in a very
big coffin that's been getting a lot of
nails in it for a long time uh there's
been a lot of problems with the dollar
reckless spending reckless printing of
new money going back to 2008 uh you know
giving
billions and trillions to bankers and
cronies and uh foreign misadventures all
over the world wasting trillion dollars
uh you know droning and killing people
you know very very very bad policies so
there's a there's a lot of problems and
the the world uh for a long time you
know since our invasion of iraq uh we've
been on a
decline in some ways you know the lot of
a lot of the world is not happy about
having the dollar be a reserve currency
and frankly the dollar just isn't
as good as it was it's it's it's a it's
a crappy coin you know it's uh
it's it's you know they're printing it
from thin air the supply is uh you know
not properly controlled uh so so yeah
that's a problem and overall with
sanctions i'm against sanctions in
general um people should be able to make
the trades that they want it's not
government's job to decide who can trade
with who if if individual citizens don't
want to deal with ukraine or don't want
to do russia or they don't want to deal
with israel or saudi arabia or taiwan or
china that should be up to the
individual
yeah when you start to think about uh
bitcoin obviously bitcoin is this
decentralized digital money uh i
continue to say that bitcoin is
protected under free speech software
software is free speech uh eef and many
others um i think it's the bernstein
versus the department of justice it's
the kind of landmark case um is that one
is that your read that bitcoin is uh
free speech protected absolutely i
quoted that exact exact case before
bitcoin is speech here's a neat thing
four years ago
four years ago the city of plattsburgh
new york said that they were going to
ban bitcoin mining and i warned it you
can see my tweets on this i warned i
said well what if i said right in the
tweet straight i said what if what if
it's town claims to do it next what then
the state is going to complain you know
claim the right to do it
um i challenged it i was with the
bitcoin foundation at the time as a
volunteer
uh i served as both executive director
and board member i think i was probably
board member and i wrote a letter to
plattsburgh and i said is the the law
defined they they said we're gonna
outlaw bitcoin mining because they're in
a town that had uh some issue with uh
power plant or whatever they had bitcoin
miners that came in there we're taking
advantage of that power and they said
we're going to ban bitcoin mining and i
looked at the law and it defined mining
as three or more computers so i wrote
him a letter i said well if i come
there
with with three raspberry pi's uh are
you gonna arrest me i mean what are you
gonna do am i in violation of your rule
if i carry them in my suitcase
you know and uh you know maybe maybe one
of those has maybe i put shakespeare on
the blockchain you know maybe i just
like looking at a blockchain you know
that's my right you don't need to do
that because the court case bernstein
already shows code is speech it's not
the government's job to decide which
speech is which these ones and zeros in
the bitcoin code are every valuable as
shakespeare uh and to many bitcoiners
they're just as valuable as any book
there is and that's our right that's our
right just as much as it's our right to
read the quran or read the bible uh or
read shakespeare and we can write and
read that code and that's our right as
americans that's a human right and and
for somebody to say that you know people
with um
you know fancy titles in a fancy office
have the right to say that you can't run
the code or read the code that you want
to run on your computer is absurd so
absolutely it's a free speech issue and
it's something that we've got to protect
and i hope that this new york
decision gets overturned by the courts
and it should
talk to me about bitcoin mining you
mentioned new york uh trying to put a
moratorium maybe as their latest uh um
uh uh effort and that moratorium is on
new miners who are not 100 renewable is
basically what they're trying to target
uh the fifth amendment gives right the
uh people the right to private property
do you think that bitcoin is protected
under the fifth amendment uh and
mining is basically the ability for
someone to secure and protect that
private property
yeah for sure i mean i think that so
your property is also your miners you
know the computers and you you have a
right in america to own a computer
and you can run whatever software you
want on it you can type whatever words
you want and there's a person named
satoshi many years ago who type some
words some words and some numbers
and i like that person and i'm going to
run that person's software and you're
not going to stop me
you know that's it so is the thought
process that these types of efforts at
the state level eventually get struck
down as unconstitutional like like play
this out for me in terms of certainly
should how it certainly should it's it's
a very very solid case for speech
because what is a bitcoin mine you're
running the software and you can do that
right on i mean you could i think you
could do it on your phone if you're a
little bit clever you can certainly do
it on a raspberry pi you're not going to
get many bitcoin doing it that way
you're not going to get any but uh
you you can run that software and
software is words and numbers and the
bernstein decision says that it's speech
cause clearly it is words and numbers
are speech
and in america we have a right to to
print speech and running speech you know
running a you know compiler or uh
hitting execute or running an executable
file that that's a form of speech
absolutely and that's all it is now this
this particular speech running this
program uh throws off these weird do you
know do hickey widget things called
bitcoin
okay i mean that that's the thing that's
within the code that that's not
you know that's not something that
because of that it gives anybody any
authority to say what speech you can
have or what what you what kind of code
you can run on your computer so the
whole thing is just absurd and this is
kind of kind of a bigger issue with the
overall creep that we see we see with
the s sec with esg
you know initiatives other initiatives
where you have government trying to get
more and more in the into the lives of
people and businesses saying well you
should run this software and this is
okay and it's not a waste to
watch porn or netflix or the kardashians
but it is a waste to run this ledger
verification thing that you want to run
or or whatever and and these kind of
things just don't have a place in a free
society
talk to me about esg you mentioned esg
and uh there's a debate uh some people
think it's the greatest thing since
sliced bread and we should all change
our lives because of uh uh the feel good
esg story uh there's other people who
think it's absolute [ __ ] and a
complete scam where are you on that
spectrum and how do you see bitcoin
interacting or related to esg
initiatives
yeah i'm concerned about it because it's
a way for government and other
authorities i mean the people who say
they like esg that's great people should
be able to do and like whatever they
want any business should be able to have
whatever kind of screens or uh
you know business style that they want
and people should be able to buy an
investment business or deal with that
business but what we're seeing with esg
is kind of a very heavy-handed top down
and in many cases government-driven
initiative and you have government
initiatives you know in the sec has also
had diversity issues now now they want
to know who is on your board and these
things uh and many of these things are
well meaning but they interfere with
governance and the way that things
should work in the in the world we
shouldn't have government authorities
who are able to come in and make these
kind of decisions and um you know tell
people how to run their business you
know that that's just not a workable
system you know might sound good it
might even have you know
well-intentioned goals
um like diversity is in many cases a
well-intentioned goal it's not the play
of government to do that because then
you end up with with power brokers and
tyrants in charge and you end up with
you know kind of different sets of rules
for different people and all kinds of
other problems that you see in failed
economies and authoritarian states
so i'm very very concerned and it is
all-encompassing you know environment
social and governance if you you can put
pretty much any aspect of a company into
one of those boxes and
claim controls and they do have that now
with with official uh public company
filings and these kind of things there's
quite a bit of control that doesn't have
to do with necessarily what the people
running the business want to do and
that's that's wrong a business just
should be run by the people that run
them and those decisions should
ultimately be made by the shareholders
what is the
bitcoin critics greatest argument like
if you were the critic and you had to
argue them better than uh they argued
themselves like what do you think has uh
validity to it
that's a great one
best critic i would say
i mean for bitcoin specifically i've
always and this is i got a lot of flack
from this i deleted a tweet one time
because so much like it wasn't because i
got the flack but because i think it was
really misunderstood but what i said was
something about
uh you know self-custody i've been in
bitcoin a long long time but i came from
traditional finance where we never did
in custody uh when i was a little little
kid my mom's brokerage office was robbed
by an armed robbery and that was
probably one of the last times a
brokerage office was was robbed i don't
think you've seen brokered uh brokerage
firms robbed since the 60s or 70s
nobody robs merrill lynch or robin hood
uh because there's no actual money there
it's all electronic um
sorry what was that i lost what do you
think is what what do you think is the
best critique of bitcoin oh right so the
critique is is about the um you know the
custody you know coming from the
investment world you know i'm not i'm
just not comfortable with it i've never
been comfortable with it i'm probably
much technically advanced than sort of
your average person not your average
person and maybe your average person in
bitcoin but certainly i'm not i'm not
like a developer or something i'm pretty
techy you know compared to you know
whatever most average folks but i've
never been comfortable with the level of
risk with you know you know self-custody
the fact that you can that that you can
lose your money that it can be uh you
know there's different ways people can
get it and there's risks and a lot of
people who've been around a long time
have seen different things happen so you
know that is a concern and i i i'm
really optimistic about companies like
casa and others who you know there's a
whole bunch of smart companies have been
working on solving this problem but i
don't think we're quite quite there yet
we're not to the point where
me as an investment advisor remember i
managed my own money but also other
people's money where i could become
totally comfortable so uncomfortable uh
with the custody thing i do lose a lot
of sleep about it i worry about it and
stresses in the land so i'd say that's a
valid uh a valid concern yeah it's uh
it's one of those that i think uh uh is
so well accepted in the bitcoin
community self-custody that uh that
having you asked that uh and kind of
question it uh is interesting um when
you think about where bitcoin is today
uh i think that you got into bitcoin in
like 2011 2012.
what's the thing that has surprised you
the most over the last decade
that's a good one um
it's funny you know a lot of people it
was more like 2012 2012 13 by 13 i was
full-time
and a lot of us talked about kind of
becoming global money they'd say you
know maybe they'll hit 3 000 or 5 000 or
10 000.
but it's been very interesting to to
actually see it happen and uh i pictured
it would be very very big
i got in real early you know like i said
i jumped in full time it was it was a
nothing industry that back then but i
thought it was going to be a big end
just
but not a
quite different thing you know you you
go to giant events that i go to and it's
just something to see that many people
you know it's really really
really stunning maybe it's just
oh we got you
did i freeze no you're good yeah this
the scope and scale i think has just
been
amazing to see firsthand you know to see
that the the number of companies and
also the money you know some of these
companies are just so huge it's really
interesting to see coming from like a
startup environment which is what the
entire space was i mean it was really an
experiment in those early days you know
there was a lot of people who weren't
even doing it for business they were
just doing because they thought it was
cool and there's a few people thinking
like oh maybe i'll make some money on
this i'll make some you know and it's
and it's kind of sad you look at the
businesses they're like oh i'll make
t-shirts or i'll make pins or i'll make
an exchange you know different decisions
that people could have made earlier in
those early days um you know you some of
the startups you could have invested
things you know that that's really uh
it's really been fun it's been a great
great journey to watch this unfold
talk to me my last question for you is
around the uh senate race uh
what are the odds you win what are the
uh the other candidates what what's kind
of the breakdown of your specific race
yeah so i've got great chances because
um
the incumbent is very weak uh her name's
maggie hassan she's a democrat she's
only served one term she only won by a
thousand votes last time
and um there was another candidate in
that race who got 17 000 votes and he
endorsed me the first
day that i announced um
so you know definitely the votes are
there uh she you know she's very
unpopular a lot of democrats are you
know unfortunately for them are very
unpopular uh right now um because you
know of the view that their their
policies have failed and and that joe
biden has failed and i think her
policies have certainly failed uh this
is a sort of purple state it's gone back
and forth it's you know more red i think
than blue so that's another reason it
could shift um and then for the primary
so i've got to win the primary and the
general but what i can bring to it that
no other candidate can is i i think i
have the broadest appeal there's
actually some
democrats that support me because i'm
i'm anti-war and against the drug war
uh i'm pro-gay marriage i'm you know
very socially liberal on many things as
a libertarian
um
and then i can bring in certainly i
should get all of them uh and uh and i
should get a lot of independence and i
and i would get all the republicans as
well even those that are a little
you know cautious about some of my
stances so i think i have the broadest
appeal i think that um this is what
america needs right now we're in the
right time for this
and uh
ideas are right and that's that's the
most important thing people are really
fed up they're not happy with math
mandates and mandated injections they're
not happy with the price of
gas and everything else uh where can we
send people to find you on the internet
so uh bruce fenton.com is my website
and uh you know that's my twitter handle
and my main um
you know social media bruce fountain you
know i've got videos on youtube on most
of the things out there
there we go so at bruce fenton on
twitter bruce fenton.com
beautiful website right there
cypherpunk capitalist what about the
connection
all right bruce
i appreciate you coming on that's right
for forever and always all right well
thank you very much bitcoin og running
for senate in new hampshire
best of luck my friend and we will talk
soon
thank you very much you have a good one
all right later